[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up broth
[Laughter]
yeah well today we are again looking at
current events did you woke up this
morning
I woke up but do something different
okay all right I hope we're not to work
yeah
so let's ask the
Holy Spirit to Enlighten us and help us
in this discussion that we can be awake
let's be awake to work
I Heavenly Father
thank you thank you for blessing us and
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to do these discussions
we once again ask you to please
enlighten our minds with the Holy Spirit
guide our minds and Enlighten everything
that we have to put through a give
through to the viewers in Jesus name
amen amen
to think that they even think up
terminology like woke yeah
to describe a situation it sounds like a
thought pattern yeah it sounds like
the enlightenment era yes and you can't
believe that something as ludicrous can
take place
so if you just just say when the light
Enlightenment era came man was put
higher ease thoughts is this the same
with this woke thing but you know Martin
if you go back into the Bible
and you read what Solomon said there's
nothing new Under the Sun
wasn't Sodom and Gomorrah awoke exactly
went the Israelites and The Tribe of
Benjamin who woke so that eventually
there were only 600 of them left
and they only found one town that didn't
participate
in the chastisement of Benjamin and they
only got 400 young ladies out there and
they needed 600 and then they needed to
steal another 200 so that the tribe
wouldn't disappear
and how many thousands and thousands of
people died
in order for this problem to be solved I
think we are heading for a terrible time
of shaking yeah
exactly because
the wokeness didn't Escape Israel so
that so it means it won't escape the
church it won't escape the church either
it will spill over into the church now
it's going to be a big deal outside of
the church Sodom and Gomorrah wasn't
that outside of the church exactly yes
so it happened there and lot in his
family
were well entrenched so that most of
them didn't want to even budge but
rather died in that City
or in those cities
but within the church itself it seems
that everything was not too
acceptable you know even lot's daughters
they were pretty awoke yeah they had
some pretty weird ideas
and so it eventually spills over even
into the church
and when the Israelites went to chastise
Benjamin
the Lord first permitted that
the others were also chastised thousands
upon thousands and Judah died and in the
other tribes died and the Lord weeded
out the wokeness
until they were of one mind
so that's what must happen in the church
but we're going to not talk about the
church today no we first we're going to
look at Sodom and Gomorrah and we're
going to look at the world first right
and then you will know if these things
start creeping into the church then
let's shout Benjamin beware
Benjamin beware
and the whole of Benjamin didn't want to
hand over those criminals
because they identified with them
so beware that you don't identify
and let's just
get a little bit typological before we
start this thing
so you've titled it Grammys Super Bowl
politics and Christian Unity
and the reason why we have all of these
things is to swing the pendulum
so you see you put in all the buzzwords
there right yeah that's it and now there
are two Christian unity and
unfortunately there's a false Christian
Unity as well yes so that's actually the
one that's meant in there of course of
course
well the world is going more and more
liberal
I don't know whether you can classify
this quite as the work but it's all part
of it the liberalization of the thinking
patterns of the world well if you take
the one part of wokeness the transgender
lgbtq
this the drug world and the love world
and all of this it's part of it it's
part of it so obviously each part of the
woke movement now I know that our newers
our viewers probably know but you were
pretty much in in that world before
you became a nerd yeah
no
and uh you and your wife were DJs at
underground Rave parties and
that drug scene was very much part of it
and of course it doesn't stay with the
drug scene it goes with the with the
other scene as well where everything
goes and whether it is gender or whether
it is transgender eventually the
distinctions become so blurred there's
nothing the thing is there's one thing
that you also hear these days a lot it's
the word love yes you have the love
parade all of these especially the
electronic dance scene is a lot about
love
but that is like we've said the
Distortion it's not love it's
licentiousness exactly
are you burnt are you a brand plucked
from the fire oh yeah well we all are so
we are all
damaged goods but uh I'm glad you're
sitting here today I am thankful to God
that he didn't give up that he didn't
give up
all right so here's an article which
says that Vancouver embarks on Bold
experiment to decriminalize hard drugs
it first started with marijuana
weed
and then eventually you decriminalize
that and then you move on to the next
one
and all the the hallucinogens
are becoming legal because basically
we're living in a meta world so why not
create even a metal body to adapt to
have the reality to to to co coexist
with the virtual but I just want to also
say yeah you see once again
okay not particularly all these hard
drugs but the marijuana for instance
once again
uh something and I've always said this
is for me a problem when you start
getting medical terms and
all of these things to justify why you
can do sin yes
so for instance it's medicinal to do sin
eventually exactly now it's either
medicinal or it's good for your
depression you see and a glass of wine
too it's good for your heart so they
claim
but the the evidence speaks to the
contrary doctors claimed in what in the
50s that smoking is good for your lungs
exactly so that's where it always where
it starts and if you think of all the
the drugs that are actually legal
like caffeine for example or theobromine
which you find in Cocoa products and
chocolates these are all legal drugs
they're narcotics yes but they're the
first step and then you move on to the
next one and the next one and the next
one you know what eventually if you ask
anybody that was
addicted to any of the heart I don't
know anybody
I know if well any guys if you ask them
if they come off this
what is the first thing you go to it's
the legal ones the legal one either they
get either they don't even know they're
addicted to the caffeine or to the theob
bromine yes when we when I became a
Seventh Adventist I didn't and I stopped
drinking alcohol the first thing I
grabbed was Coca-Cola of course and I
didn't even realize it why
because there is a reason caffeine is
addictive yes and one a day two a day if
you can't leave it if you can't get let
go of it then it's an addiction that's
absolutely what it is so anyway four
years after legalizing recreational
marijuana
Canada will again display its
Progressive drug policy Bona feeders on
January the 31st when a law to
decriminalize the personal possession of
hard drugs in British Columbia takes
effects The Province will no longer
criminally persecute adults age 18 and
over
were caught with less than 2.5 grams of
hard drugs including heroin morphine
fentanyl cocaine
mutton what's the matter with them
well it's sign of the times
that which is unacceptable in the word
becomes acceptable to society
and of course the war the word will have
to be put aside soon they will have to
criminalize the world
like they did with uh for example the
lbgt movement
in in Canada if you even quote those
verses in the Bible you can get into
serious trouble
so I've always said you know when they
asked me how do you feel about the
things
and then I would say probably the same
like God feels about them and they would
say how does God feel about them I said
you have the resources go and read it
for yourself
now that's the way I got around it
instead they will be offered information
on social programs and treating
if they request it
so the experimental will last for three
years I hope that when the experiment is
over the world will be over as well
I also hope so let's hope so
so
and it follows a move that was also
done in Portugal
it was the first country to
decriminalize hard drugs in 2001.
and the U.S state of Oregon which did so
in 2020
yeah tourists are often shocked to see
Ella alleys close to some of the main
shopping areas filled with heroin
addicts
now I was in British Columbia many times
and when you walk through the CBD area
downtown Vancouver
everywhere you find needles and they
have specific places like little
monuments or something where they where
they sit everything is packed with
needles on the floor it's it's
absolutely horrendous
and you walk past some of these faces
they are so spaced out the eyes are
totally empty
and you wonder to yourself is that what
humanity is all about emptiness
whereas God says I have come to give you
life to the full
these things promise you a life of
emptiness suffering and eventually
death so sad
and they decriminalize it well it's part
of the signs of the times so we
shouldn't complain
fortunately this experiment will only
run for three years and hopefully the
Lord will end at them for them but do
you think this type of things can also
lead to what we are actually talking
about here this pendulum to a more
driven that people want to get rid of
this well you'll have parents that will
see the effects on the children
some parents of course encourage their
children because they are themselves
hooked
but there is still a large core that
realized there's something inherently
wrong in all of this
and eventually the pressure when they
see the results and the destroyed lives
where people will say this has gone far
enough
I think so because if you listen to how
the
religious people the religious right for
instance are talking this is one of the
things that's really rallying them up
yes so yeah
well let's see where it goes we don't
want to advertise what the world is
doing but it's so in the face now
already that we might as well talk about
some of these issues
some Modern if we look at what happened
in the Grammys the performances that
were there that were lauded as the
greatest achievements
and received the prizes and the
accolades
and it was all about
transgenderism and all of these issues
to make it popular yeah
so it really reminds me of the State of
Affairs of some of those people in Sodom
and Gomorrah and the benjamites exactly
you the Bible is so accurate yes when it
says as in the days of Noah and as in
the days of lot I think
Leviticus and Deuteronomy and all of
these books
um must be incredibly unpopular
oh yes oh yes Leviticus 18 19 20 21 if
people were to read that and compare it
to the work area
it would read like a who's who
[Laughter]
well let's see what happened at the
Grammys we won't show at all just a
little bit and then we'll have a talk
about it earlier in the night the pair
won best pop Duo group performance for
their hit song Unholy and while
accepting the award Kim was so excited
to make history as the first transgender
woman to win in the category Sam
graciously wanted me to accept the sword
because I'm the first uh transgender
woman to win this award a stage in a
cage surrounded by dancers with whips
Sam rocked a bright red top hat with
horns while belting out the song for the
audience and the crowd went wild for
their performance
well we don't have to show more no it's
better not to they are better not to we
don't want to glorify them it's
interesting they wear the red and they
wear the horns so they have no qualms
about showing the satanistic origin of
their thinking patterns yeah and you
mustn't remember there's no age
restriction on the Grammys yes so kids
and everything are watching this well
now I've also looked at a few comments
on this and especially people that want
that promotes this and people were
writing against okay they were not
satisfied and now openly satanic if this
was and the people who for this said but
why this is just art
this is not art this is according to the
scripture this is an abomination
and uh and let's not even talk about
that a man may not wear what pertains to
a woman etc etc so it's just a mindset
now we have consistently said we're not
on soap boxes we are observers right we
are
trying to see where this is leading yes
not getting into the nitty-gritty as to
why and wherefore and how wrong it is
ETC that's a soapbox and everything is
there in the Bible in any case so it's
we're just taking a step back and saying
okay where is this leading why is it now
so in your face
it is to Rouse certain sensibilities
uh the Bible says the wicked will do
wickedly and the others will be
disgusted
and this divide is becoming greater
right
that's the thing it's rubbing will it
eventually come to a point of clash the
Bible says yes
King of the North King of the South will
come to a clash even if they sit at the
same table
so on the one side you have those that
stand for the woke agenda and of course
the current Administration is in the
United States is largely on that side of
the agenda and then in the background
you have those that are opposed to it
and of course Governor Ron DeSantis is
one of those who is quite vocal in this
sphere and his popularity is soaring yes
he's actually maybe becoming a rival for
trump it could be let's see where this
leads
I see Trump as all kinds of nicknames
for him and making jokes about him it's
all part of a game oh yes
they do this thing in Davos they're
doing it next week all these Elites come
in
um you know the world economic forum and
basically
um you know their vision is they run
everything and everybody else is just
like a surf like a peasant they say
they're going after energy ESG all these
other things and you see the Biden
Administration once the the next gas
stoves are you kidding me like we need I
want guestives I mean imagine like you
how many people had the hurricane come
through didn't have power right away but
were able to turn on uh some so you
cannot go down this road but that's
exactly uh what they want to do and it's
really weakening uh Western Society
Western values but underlying a lot of
that is the CCP you know those people
are there they're Elites but you know XI
is is really um is really kind of the
the puppet behind the curtain on a lot
of this stuff so very very problematic I
think in the direction they want to go
and what I've said in Florida is is that
type of stuff coming out of Davos those
policies are Dead on Arrival in the
state of Florida
to put it in a nutshell to many this
sounds like the voice of reason
and the other side sounds like the voice
of insanity right yes
depending on what size I want to be on
exactly we're not climbing on a sub box
let's just make that clear again
the interesting thing is some of these
things are so ridiculous
like Banning gas stoves
for the sake of the environment it is so
pathetic that anybody should see it and
you wonder how can people actually be
that stupid well I just have to put
another in one India they want to make
the dosage of anesthesia less because
that is also now committing to
greenhouse gas so rather have some pain
pain some pains you don't have to have
green complaining but we want to get
this tooth out after all in the Middle
Ages we just yanked it out so you better
grin and bear it
so why would they do something that
obviously makes them look ridiculous in
the eyes of some
it's a game
it's an agenda
and I'm wondering if they're sitting and
planning what can we irritate the people
with next you see I was thinking about
this because the problem is I'm sure
that a lot of people that are part of
this game don't even know they're part
of it probably they're playing it so
well that many don't know they don't
know Anthony must remember who sits
behind on top of all this nonsense is
Satan himself certain himself and his
cronies the Jesuits and all of those and
the Knights of Malta
so we have this conflict and so you'll
have the ultra liberal side doing its
thing and then you'll have the
conservatives doing the contrary
and another great player in this game is
of course Disney oh yes now we must
remember
that Disney was founded by Walt Disney
that's why it's called what Disney and
he was a 33 degree Freemason
and I think he's somewhere on ice
because he wants to be resurrected when
the technology is available
uh I think it's going to stay on ice for
a while and then maybe another thousand
years or so yes then there will be a
reason then there will be a resurrection
but they had an agenda oh and if you
look at the subliminals in in Disney
some of them are horrendous they have
everything from
subliminal uh debauchery to pedophili
everything is not in there but it's so
well hidden
so now the New York Post said that
Disney has a new sheriff in town Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis boasts
he's going to take care of them he's
going to sort them out they're going to
tell the line we're no longer going to
tolerate this wokeness
this is obviously now going to be
controlled by the state of Florida so
Disney World is in Florida and
Disneyland is in California and then of
course you have some other Disney Worlds
in the other parts of the world as well
so we're not going to allow them to
self-govern yeah because that's one
thing about Disneyland in Florida
it was making it that is its own
government and own rules and that system
that's how powerful they are
so that's what the Santa said at the
press conference in Osceola on Wednesday
so there's a new sheriff in town and
that's just the way it's going to be
we're going to take these guys and sort
them out that's basically what he's
saying and the people are cheering right
so this is interesting and then it says
has targeted Disney for months after the
company executive publicly bashed the
state's passage of the Republican back
don't say gay law
and if you look at it Martin
there you had Disney he was a 33 degree
Freemason
so these people are heavily into the
Masonic agenda yes
to create order out of Chaos and then on
the other side on the conservative side
you also have the Freemasons
and some of them are Skull and Bones
members as we mentioned and there's been
a lot of talk on the internet where does
Rhonda Santos fit in
and here's an article in the capitalist
is Ron DeSantis a member of skull and
bones
is he anti-vaxx is Florida a low-vac
state so yeah just some of the questions
so the capitalists confirmed through a
well-placed source that the centers was
not in skull and bones
but they're just speculating right you
know for sure some say it belongs to
Catholic societies
others say belongs to other societies so
there will be those that shout
conspiracy conspiracy but you know if
they are in this level of government
they're probably Associated somewhere
right somewhere
all right so the source was likely
referring to desantis's membership in
yales and Elmo Society
which Wikipedia describes as an open
secret society so
it's part of me it's part of secret
societies yes and that sent Elmo's
Society is also linked to some other
society that has a Maltese cross they're
all linked there and they are often
members of more than one Society in
different echelons
where eight men and eight women are
selected each year based on Scholastic
standing his or her seriousness of
purpose maturity individuality
other achievements at the university the
scientist's name is even listed on the
Wikipedia page under notable members
section
so his membership with Saint almost
isn't exactly a big secret so he belongs
to secret societies yes but what is
interesting is after this article came
out
if you try and search for his name now
on that Wikipedia page in the notable
section there's nothing there and
there's quite a few people that's
outraged because of that and there are
videos that you're going to see that
they actually did
so they're trying I can verify it I
think they're trying to create them Mr
Clean image right now my problem is if
this was so say for instance because you
get a lot of people people can change
can't they and we always give people the
benefit benefit of the doubt but if it
was so okay like for instance let's take
William Miller he was a Freemason yes
but he resigned from Freemasonry before
because he realized something and we've
you've got the proof of that shown
so instead of removing the name from
Wikipedia why not just
uh defend it correct so now it's
interesting that if you mentioned
William Miller he was a Freemason and he
resigned from that organization and
Joseph Smith
the prophet of the moments he did
exactly the opposite he boasted about he
being inaugurated into the highest
degrees of Freemasonry so you have all
of these interesting things but
nevertheless Martin the universities
these things are often associated with
universities
so the universities in days of old
were extensions of the church yes yes so
they were actually theological
seminaries in a sense then they became
Institutes of learning
and when the Jesuits
tried to destroy the Protestant
Reformation with which they have been
very successful
then they started this program of
learning against learning and they
infiltrated all the universities of the
world
so in a sense the Jesuit agenda controls
virtually all universities yes and
School curriculum as well everything
and there you have this learning against
learning and it excludes scripture yeah
you cannot allow a Divine foot in the
door yeah except when you get to
Georgetown then you have to study
the Jesuit way of the Bible
and Georgetown of course is the think
tank for
uh the elite in American government if
you want to get somewhere in government
it will be good to go to Georgetown and
be educated by the enemies of God and
man the Jesuits well even the medical
leaders in if you want to be there
telling everybody what to wear and what
to do
like uh fauci like Uncle fauci I'm glad
he's retired I wonder who his Jesuit
replacement is going to be just for for
interest sake but nevertheless so at
these Institutes of learning they
initiate you into the process and it is
really so they look at those people
that can be of benefit to the cause
and they draw them in
and even when I was at University I was
invited to attend certain societies but
I was such a square peg and a round hole
I just never actually did fit in
and so uh I never ever you know joined
any of those societies fortunately
but I got so annoyed when I was at the
University
because there's some young upstart comes
along
and it just passes You by and gets
promoted to the highest position
and he's done virtually nothing
to actually say why why would he why
would this be
and uh and I got so annoyed because it
never happened to me
and so I once went to the leadership and
I asked them excuse me I just don't
understand why does this person
who is just recently become uh
associated with the department and he's
just received his PhD why is he now
already a professor he doesn't even have
any postgraduate students what's going
on here is there is there anything that
I'm missing
and why am I am still stuck where I'm
stuck and they said to me well there's
no position available in your direction
at the moment so sorry
so I got annoyed
and uh then I got a an offer at another
University a big university in South
Africa
to come and help there and I said well
what position and of course they had to
up me one and so I went back to my
university and said so you say there's
no possibility of anything like this or
even though these other people that
belong to these societies just get there
and he said none whatsoever and I said
here's my resignation thank you
okay what happened
so now I got an offer from another
University within one day
I was promoted a job opening job opening
it suddenly just appeared out of the sky
so if you don't belong to these
societies you have to claw Your Way to
the Top If you want to get anywhere in
this world
but uh anyway so was he a member is he
not a member I don't know and and it
doesn't matter let's see where it let's
see where it leads
so you know Martin in politics you have
the black and you have the white and you
have the gray area
and you have some politicians that seem
to jump from one fence to the other
and Lindsey Graham is one of them and
there are some people that are fed up
with him and saying his supporting the
woke agenda or not the woke agenda
necessarily but the Biden agenda and
even the Communist the gender and others
are saying otherwise and some of them
are for some of the actions and against
some of the actions so the whole debate
is being stirred right constantly we're
observers right we're watching
we're almost in World War one type
battle conditions in the East it's
impossible in my view to dislodge the
Russians by the ukrainians unless they
have tanks we also believe that longer
range Rockets will help stop the
counter-offensive that is building in
the East the goal is to dislodge the
Russians from Ukraine by helping the
Ukrainian military in that endeavor give
them the weapons they need to beat the
Russians on the battlefield how many
times have you heard we like Trump
uh policies but we want somebody new
there are no Trump policies without
Donald Trump
I was there we live in a danger
the good news for the Republican party
there are many many talented people for
years to come but there is only one
Donald Trump
Joe Biden's weakness and incompetence
has brought us to the brink of nuclear
war and now Biden is doing what he said
10 months ago would lead to World War
III he is sending in American tanks it's
far past the time for all parties
involved to pursue a peaceful end to the
war in Ukraine before this already
horrific catastrophe spirals out of
control and ends up leading indeed to
World War III and this would be a war
like no other War because this would be
a nuclear war
Martin where's the world heading to
isn't it heading towards peace peace yes
and sudden destruction and then sudden
destruction so at some point there must
be some form of peace right
which isn't really a piece but which
leads to destruction yeah because this
whole War I mean if you
we can probably set another session and
just talk about the war
the logic that's in there yeah it's
absolutely there's no logic they want to
send these tanks it takes 42 weeks
for somebody to learn how to use the
tank yes they're training them now in
Poland apparently how to use the tanks
so and then eventually like I've heard
another person say or some general or
Colonel that for every hour that tank
runs you need a two-hour maintenance on
it yes are they going to send the troops
that do the maintenance with this or are
you just going to have a lot of broken
tanks do you see and then you send send
40 tanks and then they ask the question
now 40 tanks going to make a massive
difference this is all a major major
activity I've also heard it say
that these unidentified fly flying or
floating objects
are a distraction
to focus the world and what is happening
up here and China is doing this and that
and the other while they were getting
away with murder on the other side with
their other little how many times have
they done that before yes and then they
call a meeting at the White House to
inform the press as to you know what
color the balloon was and what kind of
gas was in it and the whole world is
focused on this well over here on the
other side they are moving their things
into position
observers right I was just
um scared one of the objects might be
the international
um
space station that they blew out of the
sky yes
catastrophe well they already blew the
oil pipeline out of the water so we
might as well blow something out of the
sky as well
but there's an agenda
and where is the agenda heading so you
have this argument that the Biden
Administration is is fermenting War by
supplying all of this weaponry and
Britain is wanting to supply airplanes
or are they not going to supply
airplanes and Donald Trump says no
Russia we should make a friend of Russia
we should work together with Russia then
we would have world peace I have you
know peace peace peace and safety these
ideologies the pendulum eventually will
have to swing in the direction of Peace
yes but because it is a piece based on a
false premise
it will lead to sudden destruction and
once again I think quite a while back we
showed who has to be
like let's say the father of the Peace
that's where everything you have to have
a father of this is going to be Trump or
is it going to be DeSantis or is it
going to be Pence or perhaps a lady well
whoever it is she'll be answering to the
other father they are all subject to the
man with the little white hat on his
head right
so Pope Francis says sport is a metaphor
for life
we're just dealing with all all of the
issues that are happening in the world
we're looking at the left we're looking
at the right we're looking at the work
we're looking at the war
we're looking at the distractions the
tools the the tools of distraction to
keep people occupied and to keep the
agenda in front of their eyes so if
you're going to have sport you're not
only going to have sport you're going to
have woke in the sport are you going to
wear lgbtq t-shirts or not are you going
to Bow the knee or are you not are you
going to you know etc etc it has to be
in the public eye you have to have like
we've always said the King of the South
pushing against the king of the north
right now so Pope Francis said that
Sports is a metaphor for life
what is the spirit of Prophecy say
you should plow up the fields and plant
potatoes right the sports fields
and uh you know that that is such a
shocker to the world it's a directly
opposite of what the world is telling
you about yeah so people look for a gray
area yeah and even within this church
they will largely be in the gray area
and not on the side of what the Bible
you know they rose up to play
they were performing the Gilgamesh Epic
getting the ball into the hull or into
the net which is the victory Of The Sun
God over his enemies which is the
victory of Lucifer over Christ you know
people don't get that uh history
so the Holy Father that's such a
blasphemy I I struggle to read it
told those present that when they travel
for championships they are called upon
to Bear witness to your bond with the
Holy See
isn't it interesting that all of these
Mega Mega Sports companies largely
belong to Knights of maltas and Catholic
organizations yeah it is a Catholic
agenda
it is a luciferian agenda
and you know even those that you
sympathize with
like Djokovic for example
I I have great sympathy for his cause
and there are many many things with that
I would say Well done sir you stand for
something you know let not your body be
misused and dictated to by forces
outside of your control
I I stand with him on that cause but
then the other thing is they will always
introduce the religious side as well
that's great you see and not to bash
anybody any one of the people that we've
shown and that we are going to show
can make it right with Lord
and they can probably if they want to
play a big role in the end giving the
loud cry yes because once they
understand the issue they might be
halfway there
and that would be an advantage
so here's a video that was put together
by Remnant video let's just have a look
at the Djokovic and other issues Bill
Gates was present in the stadium when
Novak Djokovic won the open behold the
Christian guy who went up against the
anti-christians and won his freedom
I want to congratulate everybody who
who are celebrating Christmas on the 7th
of January to all the Orthodox
Christians I wish them peace love and
what Novak Djokovic is doing right now
is what the world desperately needs
to see do you understand
I'm not I'm not citing him as someone
who should lead our movement I'm talking
about the public figure
that is presenting an example of how we
end up getting out of this nightmare
is Djokovic before I am an athlete he
says I'm an Orthodox Christian this year
has produced the worst God mockers in
all of world history we had the baby who
made a mockery of Jesus death on the
cross Kendrick Lamar offended Christians
all around the world when he turned up
to Glastonbury wearing a diamond
encrusted Crown of Thorns so yeah when
the number one athlete certainly tennis
player in the world
comes out and says I'm Christian first
that matters
Harrison butker is a kicker for the
Kansas City Chiefs
a star player he is to many living the
dream
after training Harrison changes but not
into what you'd expect
he puts on a Catholic and serves
[Music]
what is it you get out of the Latin Mass
well number one the reverence for the
Eucharist if you go to a Latin Mass
communions receive kneeling on the
tongue
um there there's a strong understanding
of the sanctuary there's a strong
understanding of uh the altar in that
it's a sacrifice going on a lot of
parishes and a lot of young people are
starting to realize the beauty of the
Latin mass that this is the foundation
of the Catholic faith what the world
desperately needs right now
Heroes
we need people who will stand up for the
faith we need Christian Heroes people
willing to stand up and fight
is that part of the pendulum swing
movement I truly believe so
so let the world go as bad as it
possibly can
and then let's swing the pendulum back
to Christian values Christian Norms the
world needs these Heroes
now we've said this all along now my
heart goes out to them that goes out to
all of differently definitely and I wish
they could understand the conflict in
the sense of the great controversy
between Christ and Satan
and people are deceived
very much great sacrifice of the cross
Martin just contemplate the great
sacrifice of the Cross being reduced to
a morsel of bread instead of the bread
becoming a reminder of the great
sacrifice of the cross it becomes a
means of Salvation in itself it's a
horrendous Distortion of a great truth
and people are trapped in it and they
are because they are sincere in what
they do but they are so sincerely
deceived yes I wish the whole world we
should understand it wake them up yes
yes
but it's going to lead somewhere
that's going to lead to peace and then
to destruction it is and this is inside
of a Catholic Church that we've just
shown broadly there's a big fight in the
Catholic Church actually King of the
South inside there pushing against
because the liberal secularism is
pushing against the more conservative
side and this conflict is going to grow
until the conservatives say we have had
enough politically religiously
all of them put together so you must
have this push from the left
and you must have the counter push from
the right
and the Bible says who the eventual
winner is going to be
so here's an interesting article from
the BBC the Kirk moderator joins Pope in
historic South Sudan pilgrimage
now Kirk of course is church in the
Scottish countries
the moderator of the Church of Scotland
has described his historic pilgrimage
with the Pope to South Sudan as a sign
of Christian Unity
this is the first time greenshield told
BBC
since the Reformation
that's going back of a 500 years that
the three very distinctive Traditions
have Eve ever come together to do
something like this it's a sign of
Christian Unity
so does the church of Scotland that's
Presbyterian that's calvinistic then you
have the Church of England
the anglicans which is a Protestant
movement that has returned back into the
faults of Rome through the Oxford
movement
and then you have the pope himself
so Martin this is the great catastrophe
the great Unity that is coming about in
the churches that will eventually lead
to the implementation of the mark of the
beast yeah
and where does this Pope stand well Pope
and Protestant leaders denounce anti-gay
laws
so they are fermenting on the one side
yeah and you have the Conservative
Catholics and the Latin Mass Catholics
arguing on the other side
so Pope Francis and the leaders of
Protestant churches in England and
Scotland have denounced the
criminalization of homosexuality
and his comments were backed by the
Archbishop of Canterbury and the
moderator of the Church of Scotland so
all together they are pushing an agenda
we are watching them standing on their
so-called soapboxes playing a game yeah
this is like they're on purpose or
purposefully agitating and stoking the
fire
and then we go one step further with a
wokeness Church of England votes to
offer blessing to same-sex couples now
the pub doesn't go so far as to say that
the Catholic Church will do it
but he says we shouldn't have anti-gay
laws
and the governments the secular world
the judicial system must sanction gay
marriages that's where he goes so let's
keep it out of the church but do it over
there Martin
is it all right to do it over there and
it's not all right to do it in the
church or is it is it sin no matter
which way you look at it it's okay
during the week I can steal a little bit
and do a little bit of this but on
Sabbath or during church then I'm not
doing any of that rather call it Sunday
first of the week day of the week
otherwise you make me nervous yes I mean
all right the odd special of Canterbury
Justin Welby and Archbishop of York
Stephen Cottrell said in a statement it
has been a long road to get to this
point
for the first time the Church of England
will publicly unreservedly and joyfully
welcome same-sex couples in the church
if you look at it the way they voted
Martin it's interesting
because when it came to the leadership
the Bishops
Etc
they were almost unanimous not quite
almost unanimous in saying yay let's do
this when it came to the clergy
there was a slight majority that said
yes let's do this
when it became to the light the laity it
was even a smaller a group that said
let's do this so the church is really
divided and all I can say to those that
weren't happy with this decision come
out of her my people that's it come out
of her pet my people that you be not
partakers of her
sin yeah and Martin besides all that we
have the abortion debate right and you
have the administration that's currently
in power saying we are for abortion
and then you have those that are against
abortion and there's this massive debate
now all of these debates whether they
take place in sport whether they take
place in the lgbtq community whether
they take place on the abortion front
all of them are kept in front of the
public view constantly fermenting
fermenting fermenting
we must ask ourselves why
and where is it heading never forget
that because this is what it's really
about
so let's have a look at that the
Catholic Bishops demanded that the
federal tax dollars should not fund
abortion
and they said that it should and then
they decry how the champions of abortion
are being honored
and receive all the accolades
whereas the methods that they use are so
horrendously grotesque so let's just
have a look at what's going on there
Catholic Vengeance are demanding that
federal tax dollars not fund divorces no
they are not all doing that Captain
doors
the pope doing that they say says
Francis this is a person who thinks very
differently from us true but never mind
we have to look at people
at what they do
really
and what did this creature do
well before it was legal she came up
with an apparatus some sort of a suction
apparatus by which she was able to
personally exterminate 10
000 babies in Italy before going on a
war path and becoming a champion of
legal abortion in Italy and legal
divorce and drugs and everything else
she's a sweetheart
that was Francis doing meeting with her
what's he doing that for here to present
Sam CUNY award to benino is into
George Sora
Sora
thank you
[Applause]
so there you have it Soros Francis
parole boards big and small
and you're going to blame Joe Biden for
thinking maybe the Pope's not really all
that pro-life after all he said that
thing about hiring a Hitman remember
you're gonna blame Joe Rogan
and Donald Trump for going soft on the
gay thing all of a sudden right when the
pope himself has gone soft on that and
is going softer on it every day
so Martin there must be a serious agenda
in all of this
and the way that we just saw them
choosing sides you you definitely take a
soapbox and you climb onto it
and you choose sides
but you missed the point as to why are
they doing this and where is it heading
you okay they will choose sides and
eventually it'll almost come if it
doesn't come to a point of Civil War
and then eventually they will say so far
and no far further and introduce
Draconian laws
to stop all of the so-called wokeness
and within those laws you will have
other laws which are hidden in there
which will lead to destruction
now how far did this go
here's an article in news lawmakers wore
pins to the Soto that's the State of the
Union Address
to show support for several causes and
they wore pro-abortion pins and it's
interesting that the the O was in the
form of a heart basically saying we love
abortion
I mean we're in biblical times here we
are in times where malach is being
uplifted before the World by saying that
I'm climbing on a soapbox
I mustn't I must stand back yes but it
doesn't mean that we acknowledge in that
any of this is good we it there's no I
mean how how what's going on in your
head if you love abortions there's
something there must be something wrong
yes there's something wrong
but it's supposed to be like that
because you're supposed to be so
horrified that eventually you will
rejoice when the pendulum swings exactly
that's the me so how do you have to look
at this you have to look at this the way
that God would look at it yes with
sorrow in his heart that these people
are so far lost
but modern are the other people not
equally as far lost that's just a very
sad part of it so what is going to save
them in the end the Three Angels
messages must be proclaimed to open
their eyes
and then if they can embrace the truth
they can take a stand and come out of
her my people
and be not partaker of the sin whether
it is the sin on the one side or the sun
on the other side
or Martin the rain is coming down again
it hasn't debated right no it's still
sitting with it we've had more
rain in the last 14 days than we
normally receive in an entire year it's
actually a week in a week yeah seven
days yes
well Democratic senator Ed Marquis of
Massachusetts wore a pin with the word
abortion written in capital letters I'm
wearing my abortion pin from so and so
tonight's State of the Union Address
Market wrote on Twitter abortion is
essential health care and we need to
codify this right
this is to bring it to the public
attention to ferment the debate
another article in this line Christian
charity worker faces potential jail time
fine after speaking about leaving the
LGBT lifestyle
so Martin you're not allowed to leave
that lifestyle you're not allowed to
talk about it they criminalize if you
actually want to speak and tell anybody
else that you've left it yes but you can
go to schools and tell people to join it
that's correct and in uh in Britain and
in other countries it's illegal to do
any what they call prosatilizing yeah in
other words you're not allowed to
convince people that their lifestyles
are wrong so it's rather safe to stay in
Sodom rather than to leave
so Matthew Gretch 33 faces potential
fines and imprisonment for allegedly
falling a foul of his country's ban on
conversion practices
when he explained to a local media
Outlet last year how he left
homosexuality behind because he came to
believe it was wrong
it was surprised when police later
called him earlier on a Sunday morning
and ultimately served him with a
prosecution order summoning to court
he said that after LGBT activists with
ties to the Maltese government and the
malta gay rights movement
reported him to the police for the
interview he now faces up to 5 000 Euro
in fines up to five months in prison
if convicted of violating article 3 of
malta's affirmation of sexual
orientation gender gender expression act
which makes it unlawful for any person
to advertise conversion practices
now it's uh very fitting that this
should be in Malta I was thinking
exactly the same thing where the Knights
of Malta have their seat Well you know
all of them what about that sermon that
you did or the whole series of creed to
Malta wait about that maybe it's a good
idea if everybody can go and re-watch
that series I'll also put it in the
description again you'll put the link in
yes come to think of it it's Little
Light Studios also again well we always
talk about them but they do such great
work they did a wonderful documentary on
Sports so I'll put that in the
description as well then people can go
and look at it because we were speaking
about that one was exceptionally well
done I take my hats off to those people
that are doing a great job you see I
just want to mention they mentioned
there how sport is actually a religion
it is a religion it is
and where it leads to and the passions
that it creates and they show it very
very well people really go and look at
that little light studio production it
is excellent
so interestingly Martin now the debate
is so heated that anybody in the
Catholic circles that attends the Latin
mass or praise the rosary is considered
anti-liberal
Etc like a Witch Hunt
it also labeled extremists now not not
that we are promoting it but this is
just showing again this secular King of
the South movement think about it what
it is what is it creating
if there are Protestants that think that
this whole movement is wrong
and here you have Conservative Catholics
that think that this whole movement is
wrong
doesn't it create a bond of sympathy
between the two precisely like you've
got the bond of sympathy now between
those three churches
towards the work side you are agitating
the conservative
and the others and then what will they
do they will reach across the gulf and
they will take the hand of Rome and they
will March together
and they will implement the mark of the
beast
so let's have a look at this little
interesting interlude Inland extreme
outrage as it argues the Catholic rosary
the rosary is now a symbol of extremism
the article includes this animated
Rosary shaped by bullet holes arguing
today's Catholics are part of a quote
growing contingent of Christian
nationalism
Fox and Friends Weekend co-host Rachel
Campos Duffy has a rosary or two in her
purse my mom did I've got one on my desk
Rachel are they trying to cancel the
Rosary
no well who knew that you and I were
both right-wing extremists for having a
rosary and it seems funny
um but it's actually not the first thing
that authoritarians try to do Steve is
to delegitimize and ban religion because
it is a existential threat against the
state and and I think that's what you
have here and I think what they're
trying to do and we're seeing more
articles like this
um this seems comical but we're seeing
more and more articles trying to
associate people who are faithful
especially those who adhere to you know
more Orthodox or traditional
interpretations of Faith as somehow
being right-wing extremists white
nationalists fringe and I think we ought
to be very careful of that first of all
it shows a deep ignorance you're a
Catholic Steve I am um this imagery of
of the spiritual battle that we're in as
the Rosary in prayer as a weapon in the
spiritual battle at Sacramento's whether
they're holy water or whatnot against
the devil these are things we believe in
and we use that imagery because we
believe we're fighting something very
evil
um and so it shows ignorance but it's
also
um very interesting that they're trying
to associate it with violence when in
fact if you look at the aftermath of Roe
versus Wade what what kind of you know
deep projection this article is involved
in it was the other side the
pro-abortion side that was you know
um attacking churches defaming Catholics
going in front of their churches and and
doing all kinds of obscene things
so
they they are keeping it very well in
front of the public eye creating the
bond of sympathy
and slowly turning the mindsets of the
conservatives against the woke agenda
even within the Catholic Church where
they're sitting at the same table right
so you have the Vatican to investigate
the diocese that supports traditional
maths in France so it's not just in the
U.S it's worldwide it's worldwide
so I communicate from the apostolic
enunciature of France published by the
diocese on its web page
states that the apostolic visitation is
by Mandate of Pope Francis and comes
after a certain number of difficulties
encountered in the diocese
so following the promulgation of
traditions custodus Pope Francis in his
motto Pro priority
restricting the traditional Latin mass
or tridentine mass Bishop Ray
highlighted the concerns of several
priests and communities in his diocese
this is coming a long time
and it was even you know years ago there
was a bishop Le Furby
who was for the Latin mass and they
ostracized him and they've been playing
this game for a long time he's just
speaking up a little bit of steam now
here's a question mark
with whom
with which side of Catholicism
will conservative protestantism create a
bond of Union with a liberal side or
with the conservative side with the
conservative side with the
traditionalists all right
if that is the case
it is a brilliant move of strategy by
Satan with which side
was the Reformation in the time of
Luther in confrontation exactly that
side the tradition so with the
traditional side with the Council of
Trent's side those were the warring
factions today the conservative
Protestants will Unite with the
Conservative Catholics the very ones who
stand by the Council of Trent and decry
Vatican II
those are the ones they will identify
with
and those are the ones that they will
create a bond of Union with and those
are the ones where they will stand
together and say let's Implement
Christian norms and standards as
brothers and sisters in unity exactly
the Reformation will have been totally
destroyed yes 100 the Christian
nationalist movement includes this
traditional Catholics and all the
conservative Christians now let's make
people let's make people even more mad
so let's get the FBI involved and let
the FBI start targeting Catholics who
attend the Latin Mass
now that'll get even the Protestants
riled up right for sure
so for my FBI special agent and federal
whistleblower Kyle Serafin reportedly
obtained a leaked FBI document that
outlines a plan
to spy on a segment of one of America's
biggest religious denominations the
FBI's Richmond division would like to
protect Virginians from the threat of
white supremacy which it believes has
found a home within Catholics who prefer
the Latin Mass
so
fermenting the bond of Union the
churches coming together
and they will create laws so it's always
good to see how they think yes so let's
get the remnant video to tell us how
they think about these things
thousands of Warriors of Mary met in the
Basilica of Saint Vincent De Paul in
Poland to pray the rosary to attend Mass
to consecrate themselves to the same
holy war that we're fighting on this
side of the Atlantic look at this 8
000 men singing a battle song that dates
back to the 12th century
Mother of God they sing from your son
our Lord chosen mother Mary win over for
us send to us Son of God for the sake of
your Baptist hear our voices hear the
prayers that we offer give us what we
ask for Kyrie eleison
says telling the world
you cannot kill Christianity
so we say to Francis the globalists
bring it on Francis take away our Latin
Mass we've been there before we know
what to do we did it once before we'll
do it again
your persecution is only forcing us to
remember
forcing us to remember the promises of
our baptism that we had set aside for a
time to remember what we have lost
and to see in how much you hate the old
Faith how much we love it and how much
we must never ever forget it how much we
desperately need to reclaim it as our
Birthright as followers of Jesus Christ
these globalists including the pope are
making us friends they are making us
Christian again they're waking us up
God is using them to turn us back to him
to turn us back into the Christian
Soldiers of Jesus Christ that our
fathers were
and if that means martyrdom for us
well then
we were about to die
salute you
Martin
I really feel sorry for them
because they're going back to the
traditions
they're standing there with a rosary
I come from the Catholic tradition
ten Hail Marys one our father
ten Hail Marys one Our Father ten our
Mary's one hour is the rosary to help
you count the rosary has the beads so
that you say the tens there will be ten
beads which are the the one then there's
a gap and then there's a bead which is
the Our father and then there's the ten
beads and then you go down to the Creed
and you end up with a cross and then
you've said the whole thing do not be
like the pagans says the Bible to repeat
over and over and over again and in any
case Mary is asleep she cannot help you
this is paganism Revisited it is Isis
worship
and it's very very sad but this is the
kind of religion that will link up with
protestantism
thereby kicking sand into the face of
Jesus Christ again and destroying the
Last Vestige of protestantism if God
didn't have a remnant
that holds to the testimony of Jesus
and keeps the Commandments of God
there would be no one left to represent
him on this Earth that's true
and so people are lamenting the loss of
religion
but what religion are they lamenting
a false religion based on a false
premise
so here's market watch from January 2023
rise in middle-aged white deaths of
Despair may be fueled by loss of
religion
new research paper argues the working
paper from Tyler Trials of Wellesley
College Daniel hungermann of the
University of Notre Dame and Tama ustrom
from the Ohio State University looked at
the relationship between religiosity and
the mortality from deaths of despair
so what is driving people to the point
of despair
researchers looked at the repeal of blue
laws in particular what and this is
getting very interesting it's getting
very serious as well
blue laws limited Commerce typically on
a Sunday mornings
these laws have been shown to be
strongly related to religious practice
creating discrete changes in incentives
to attend religious services that are
plausibly unrelated to other diverse
religiosity they said
the repeal of blue laws had a five to
ten percentage Point impact on weekly
attendance of religious services and
increased the rate of deaths of Despair
by two deaths per hundred thousand
people they found
now I think they are dragging many of
these
statistics in by the hair yeah but they
are trying to show something they're
putting it out in the public eye yes
they want people to know we need to
return to that old-time religion you
know what unfortunately
we do have to go back to A Primitive
godliness we do but the right one is not
the false one ah this is so how serious
is it that we get the Three Angels
messages out it is life and death at
this stage everlasting life and
everlasting I feel so helpless I wish
the whole world could hear it how are we
going to just get people riled up to
start seeing where we are
El Tiempo January 16
2023 the Ten Commandments of God to stay
away from sin
yeah they're pushing an agenda let's get
back yes but look at what they're doing
for the Catholic religion The Ten
Commandments are based on this Dogma
according to the Old Testament in the
book of Exodus and Deuteronomy
God gave his decalogue to Moses on Mount
Sinai to help his chosen people to
fulfill the Divine Law and then they
give you a law which is anything but the
law in the Bible it's the Catholic one
yeah the first one you will love God
above all things it's a generic God it's
not the god that says I'm the one that
took you out of Egypt it's not Yahweh
it's a generic God it's a universal
deity it is an ecumenical one the very
first commandment that they have breaks
the first commandment you shall have no
other gods besides the one that took you
out of Egypt right correct
then the second one is you shall not
take God's name in vain where's the
second commandment Thou shalt not make
for yourself an image Thou shalt not bow
down to it
it's gone wizard God why because they
love imagery because you must have all
gods besides Yahweh that's it and you
can Embrace so much more so many more
religions into it so here is a total
annihilation of the word of God
this is the third commandment and not
the second one you will sanctify the
holy days excuse me
if you look it up in the Catholic
catechism it says that the church
commands you to keep Sunday holy and
other holidays holy days as they specify
here they've summarized it exactly
according to the Catholic stature you
will sanctify the holy days
prescribed by the church
now it's interesting before you can get
back to that
you first have to remove all of those
holy days
and bring in all the other days that
have nothing to do with it in our
country for example
I am sad to say I can identify with none
or let's say virtually none of our
so-called holy days
they are meaningless to me and in the
past there were all the religious ones
like Easter and Christmas and all of
these things and in a sense you
almost long for those days but they're
just as Pagan as the ones that we keep
now exactly
so all of these holy days they were
pre-prescribed by the church are pagan
they said so there's actually only one
holy day
still left correct and there's a
Seventh-Day Sabbath
and then they bring you the fourth
Commandment which is actually the fifth
one which says you will honor your
father and your mother they remove the
promise of course
and in the United Nations they turn it
around because child right is higher
than parental right yeah so that
commandment is gone Thou shalt not kill
well abortion kills that one
and you will not commit impure Acts
but if you define
bestiality and all of the other
movements that we discussed today as not
impure acts then what does this mean
Martin exactly means nothing
you shall not steal unless of course you
have
legitimized stealing yeah if you change
the definition of what it means to steal
yes like Thomas Aquinas already said
it's not a crime to steal and it's not
breaking the Commandments if you have
need
I don't think Jesus who would have said
that to the Widow through in the two
mights did she now have the right to go
and steal because she only had two mites
you will not give false testimony or lie
well Martin if they are our example then
I don't know where that commandment is
and you will not consent to impure
thoughts or desires that is supposed to
be the law of covetousness which they of
course divided into two and made it the
tenth one as well to make up for the
lack of the one that's missing over
there the second commandment
yourself not covet other people's Goods
unless of course you're Thomas of
kindness and uh his cronies then
whatever goes goes if you have need of
it oh I'll take this television oh I'll
take that one too because my friend has
need of it
so Martin this is a law which is totally
contrary to God's law
dressed up to look like God's law
you see if you put this law out there to
conservative non-catholics they'll agree
yes perfect let's go with it let's run
with it
this is where we're heading yeah this is
the morality that they want
so here is another article which says
give me that old-time religion did it
protect Americans from Death of despair
by the year 2017 as few as one-third of
all Americans could be Christians
according to the Pew Research Center
projections
nuns
people without an allegiance to a
religious Faith could be as many as 52
percent
the de-christianization of society is
hard to assess and harder to predict but
we can ask is this good news or bad news
according to a research paper released
last week by the National Bureau of
economic research a prominent think tank
in Cambridge Massachusetts it's bad news
it is in fact literally deadly
what proof have they to put on the table
in an original and thought-provoking use
of statistic the researchers examined
the deaths of despair
of the American states repealed their
blue laws these were laws which banned
Commerce on Sundays so that people could
observe Sabbath by attending church
services and spending more time with
their families they're talking about
that same research paper we spoke about
just now but they're just spelling it
out more direct we need Sunday laws we
need to go back to that old-time
religion
are we at the end of days
definitely
you think so the Bible says so Bible
says so when they make void thy law
then it is time to act
they have made void thy law it is time
for thee to act
talking to God lord yeah
Martin it's time for us to start acting
it's time for us to get onto a soapbox
not a woke soap box nor any of the other
soap boxes I want to climb onto a very
high Three Angels
Broadcasting soapbox let's say it's a
box let's not call it others are so
boxes we'll get on the box one box
right I think we need to pray about this
let's pray Heavenly Father
it is time for thee to act for they have
made void thy law
this is our prayer too
and Lord if it were possible
all of those priests and all of that
laity that didn't want to go along with
those votes
they are your children sitting in the
Babylonian Fallen churches they can see
that their churches have fallen they can
see where their ideologies are heading
bring them out Lord bring them out so
that they may keep the Commandments of
God and hold to the testimony of Jesus
is my prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you